hello everyone and welcome to today's
steve burger winner presentations i'm
susie valdez elaborates and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by
agilent so let's get started before we
begin i'd like to remind everyone that
this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as
many questions as you'd like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box
and click send please address your
questions to
a specific speaker we will have
answers as many questions if we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen i now present
today's speakers
first we will have passima siri
a phd candidate at university of
illinois at chicago
and he will be presenting the topic of
investigation of altered
phosphor interstitius in the
neurodegenerative
disorder at the neiman pick type c1
then dr james dodd post docked in
professor aaron baker's lab at north
carolina state university presenting
combining credentialing
at ion of mobility spectrometry and
tandem
ms to detect identity and
validate minimal life in untargeted
analysis
for complete biography on today's
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
doctor shanimo ross mari you may now
begin
your presentation welcome sir
hello everybody my name is chandimal
patmaseri from colonel lab
a department of chemistry at university
of illinois at chicago
so today i'm going to talk about a
project that we did
to investigate altered postpones in
neurodegenerative disease this is neman
peak type sibo
so first let's look at what is nematic
disease
pneumonic disease is a autosomal
recessive neurodegenerative lipid
storage disorder
the patients that has these mutations
has
mutated a patient that has that disease
has mutations in npc1
or npc2 genes so npc1 and npc2
genes make proteins that are found in
lysosome
that involves in lipid transportation so
when cells has these mutations they are
unable to move molecules like
cholesterol through the endosomal
lysosomal system and create a traffic
jam of lipid
inside the cell that led to several
downstream consequences
like inflammatory response abnormal
signaling
and neuronal cell death
to trust the right side of the slide
what we are looking at here is kelvin
and staining
so kelvin then stands for pre-k engine
neurons
what we see here is a npc one mutant
mice cerebellar
at the early stage of the disease we see
loss of protein neurons from the lobules
two and three
and with the progression of the disease
we
see that frequent neurons starts to dive
in in the other lobules too and it
continues towards the later lobules
so this is known as a antenna
neurodegeneration
in pneumonic disease type c1
so because this is a lipid storage
disorder
and has a pattern neurodegeneration we
were interested of looking at
changes of distributions in lipids with
the progression of the disease
so the best way to do that is mass
spectrometric imaging
first i will walk you through the
workflow of mass spectrometric imaging
how we do this analysis initially
we after the euthanization of animals
we dissect the tissues and flash freeze
these tissues on dry ice
so that helps to keep the special
integrity of the tissue
and then we section this tissue
into 10 micron thickness sections onto a
moldy plate
and then wash with ammonium formate so
the washing
step is optional depending on the
analysis after that we apply a matrix
using sublimation technique which gives
a very uniform
coating of matrix in this analysis
we use matrix name as nine amino acrylic
which is very good in negative eye mode
in the mass spectrometer there is a
laser
that can rust through this tissue and
each of these lasers put
creates a mass spectrum and
there are softwares like msi reader and
tissue weaver
they can regenerate heat maps
with the data that is created in this
analysis
so heat maps shows the distribution and
the abundance of
each of this lipid in the tissue we can
look at the
region of interest and also there is a
algorithm
created in our lab recently to look at
replicate analysis so what happens
in the algorithm is it filter out
noise and it does peak alignment
and normalize the signal between let's
say mutant and y type
and it allows us to create a average
mass spectrum for
all these biological and technical
replicates and
allow us to look at changes in the
abundance of lipid
so we did this analysis for this mouse
model
at week three week seven and week nine
so these are three time points that we
study this
progression of this is where week 3 is
pre-symptomatic
week 7 is symptomatic and week 9 is
pre-terminal
week 11 is the average terminal time
point of this mutant mice
in this image panel we have
npc one wild type in the left side and
npc one mutant in the right side
and what we are looking at here is the
molecule
at 10 10 45.5 m over z
what we observe is this molecule is
depleted
in the mutant compared to wild type at
all three time parts
so what is this molecule to find that
out
we did on tissue msms and looking at the
sub databases
for the fragmentation pattern we
identified this lipid as
phospho persuaded in acetyl bisphosphate
or shortly known as pip2
so type 2 is a cluster postponositis are
a class of lipids
and pip2 is one of these postponements
attacks let's look at
what are these postponed lipids
postponocites are composed of
a diacetyl glycerol which is linked to
inositol hair group
via a link of phosphate so this is
called as
postpartum inositol this molecule
can get further phosphorylated to make
monophosphorylated bisphosphorylated and
triphosphorulated postponosites
not only that but also depending on the
position of the phosphorylation
there are different positional isomers
for monophosphates and bisphosphate
interestingly these different positional
isomers has different functions
in the cell even though this
class of lipid is very important
signaling lipids
it has been very challenging to study
these lipids due to
several less reasons like the abundance
the abundance of these molecules are
very low in the mammalian cell
for monophosphate and this phosphate the
abundance is
even less than one percent from total
phospholipid
also for peep 3 it is less than
0.1 from total phospholipid
also in addition to the abundance
ionization efficiency of these molecules
in the mass spectrometer
is also very low so next i will show you
how we overcome these challenges
in order to analyze this class of
molecules in mass spectrometry
okay so up to now what we know from the
mass spectrometric imaging is that pip 2
is depleted in
the mutant compared to wild type but
we do not know which isomer is depleted
so in order to find that out and also
to study this class of lipid further
we utilize liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry
this is the workflow that we follow to
do this analysis first part is
extraction of lipid we use big triple
symptomatic
week nine pre-terminal uh mouse
cerebellar in this study
we lies the tissue in np-40 buffer which
helps to
get the membranes dissolved
and we extracted phosphonocites using
acidified blood dye extraction and then
these extracted lipids
were analyzed in two major approaches
one is
with the derivatization to this molecule
and the other approaches without a
derivation but
using a higher or uh higher ph
uh mobile phases to help to ionize this
molecule in negative eye mode
especially with this non-derivatives
method which i have shown in the
right side with the with the
green color background we were able to
separate the position and isomers of
these phosphates in the liver space
so next i will talk a little bit about
the tms derivatization method
show the data from that method and also
go to the data for the
non-derivatives method so tms
derivatization
is a very important very simple
reaction which methylate the hydroxide
that are connected to the phosphate
group
how to do this reaction is to buy
this commercially available reagent
called tms diazomethane in
xn and incubate at room temperature for
10 minutes
the benefit of the resulting molecule is
major benefit is the higher ionization
efficiency in positive ion mode and also
the resulting molecule has very minimum
carryover effect
in the liquid chromatography system
compared to the reactant
and the stability of this resulting
molecule is
higher than the reactor
this is data from this derivatized
analysis
where for pip 2 we observe the same
information
as we see in my spectrometric imaging we
are in
early and late time points this lipid is
depleted in both
uh depleted in mutant and
mutant at e3 and week nine so
in addition to that also we see
monophosphates
are depleted in a mutant at both time
points
and when it comes to the pi it is not
significantly different
at week 3 but is depleted at midnight
as i mentioned earlier in the
non-derivatized analysis
we were able to separate the positional
isomers
using liver space chromatography and we
see that pi45p2 is depleted
in mutant so pi45p2
is is the major
pip2 species in the mammalian cell
so let's look at how these molecules are
synthesized
in the cell so this starts in the
endoplasmic reticulum
where the cdp diesel glycerol converts
into postpartum inositol by linking with
a
inositol head group and then these
molecules get transported to
plasma membrane and called the apparatus
with the help of bi transfer protein
and at these locations there are kinases
and
phosphatases that can synthesize the
monophosphates bisphosphate and
triphosphate so kinases add their
phosphate to the molecule
and phosphatases removes the phosphate
from the molecule
bi is the precursor for all these
molecules
so with knowing that p i is the
precursor for
deep 2 we were
we decided to look at the distribution
of this
pi in the mouse cerebellum even though
we don't see
a significant difference in abundance at
early time points
if you look at the distribution of pi
and pip2
they are very different so tip 2
is in the white matter and p i is
in the gray matter to have a closer look
at this if you look at this overlay
image
where we see pi in red color and pip2
in blue color we see the
the clear difference so p i is
in grammar especially found more in the
granular layer
where p2 is found in white matter
white matter is rich in myelin so myelin
is very important
in this demyelination of
neurodegenerative diseases
myelin is a membrane or a insulating
wrapping around axons
which has more than 70 of
lipids and mining helps to speed up
neuronal transmission and if there is
any defects in myelin or
if any defects in the composition of the
myelin
that leads to [ __ ] impulse
coordination
when it comes to npc-1 disease
it has been known that demyelination is
seen in npciphone disease
if you look at these images which are
uh standing for myelin basic proteins so
myelin basic protein is a prominent
protein in the myelin
we see that this protein
is depleted in several regions of the
brain
suggesting the myelination is seen in
npc one disease so knowing that
information we were
interested of looking at the
compositional changes
in myelin and we decided to enrich
myelin
how we do that is we lyse the tissue in
0.35 molars across and then we pour this
onto a 0.85 moles across and do high
speed
uh centrifugation and you can see
myelin in the interface of these two
solutions
what we do is we take this myelin and
then we did postpone ac type analysis
and we see p2 and pip
is depleted in mutant
from the from the
myelin from the mutant itself
so it's suggesting that there is
changes of the combustion of lipids in
the mind
to summarize the talk first i showed you
more the mass spectrometric imaging we
will speak to depletion
and also for the analysis using
lcms we see alterations
of pip and pi
and we were able to separate people to
position
isomers chromatographically in reverse
phase using liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry
and we see a significant difference in
the
distribution of pi and pip2 which led
us to analyze myelin
and we found postponeocity altered in
the
myelin of npc one disease
with that i would like to thank my group
members
especially my pi dr stephanie mkolona
and all my funding agencies and also
i would like to thank agent and
technologies for giving me
this opportunity thank you everybody
hey everybody my name is james todds i'm
a postdoc in professor aaron baker's lab
at north carolina state university in
raleigh
uh today i'll be talking to you about my
recent research using iron mobility
spectrometry to help detect
identify and validate metabolites in the
credentialing process that's pioneered
by gary patty's lab
but before we get into that talk i want
to give a shout out to agilent
technologies
who funded my virtual travel this year
to asms with the steve berger award
for those of you who don't know steve
was an employee of agilent for some odd
26 years in the sales and marketing
department
and he also was a academic liaison
between agilent and universities and um
so when i was notified that i was going
to receive this award i did a little bit
of background information on steve
and i found a really interesting um
notification from the lansing state
journal that was published after his
death
and there's a quote there that says he
was an incredible role model for his two
sons and others around him
who would witness his actions you could
ask for a favor and he'd always say yes
without hesitation
um and i think you know maybe now more
than ever it's more important to
focus on what we can do to help and
support each other
um in these times and i think steve is a
great role model for that
uh so transitioning from uh steve's
family to my lab family here at nc state
i've been blessed with a
great group of co-workers you can see
their pictures on the left who are
interested in a variety of omics related
sciences
relating chemical information to
phenotypic outcomes
as it pertains to this talk today my
research is mostly focused on small
molecule metabolites
and that'll be the focus moving forward
i think when it comes to metabolomics
there are two main challenges that we as
a community
sort of face and those both relate to
the idea of significant features and the
first challenge is
ensuring that features relate back to
biological metabolism
and the second challenge is taking that
chemical information from just a raw
mass to charge
value and relating it back to molecular
structure
and we can use things like tandem sms to
help
lucid day molecular structure but it's
not always straightforward and the talk
that i'm going to give to you today
basically outlines how we're going to
try to address
both of those challenges all right so
the way we can first address the
challenge of relating features to
metabolism is to incorporate stable
isotope labels or isotope logs directly
into the experimental design
so if you're involved in cell culture
you're supplying energy
sources or a nutrient to your system of
interest and that's predominantly
consisting of carbon 12
say in glucose but if you incorporate
stable isotopes like heavy labeled
glucose directly into the experimental
design that carbon
heavy carbon label tracks throughout the
glycolytic pathway and other metabolic
processes
and so what you get out of that is heavy
labeled metabolites that directly come
from biology
and really the utility here is to
analyze
those samples by analytical methods like
mass spectrometry that help relate
features back to metabolism so here in
the top left portion of your screen we
have a carbon 12 and carbon 13
labeled cell culture they're grown up in
identical
environments to ensure that they produce
metabolites at the same rate
then you usually take those two samples
and do an extraction
and combine them in ratios that make
analytical sense for you to perform the
analysis
and so most often this is done in a
one-to-one ratio so now you have a
sample that contains both carbon-12 and
carbon-13 labeled isotopes
and the information you get out of that
experiment like you see on the right
is mass spectrometry information where
signals are correlated
in abundance based on the way you mix
them and so we have
a signal at mass 426 and 436 and they
have
relatively the same intensity within
some air and the key takeaway here is
that these two signals
come from one metabolite and their only
difference is that carbon label
and basically doing this process allows
us to collect
features that are directly related to
biology
there's a different variety of ways of
performing this experiment the one i'll
be talking
to you about through the most of this
process is the credentialing platform
again by gary patty's lab
there's also another one variant called
miracle and probably the most well known
of these
uh iterations is the isotopic ratio
outlier analysis or iron platform
spearheaded by chris beecher and is now
its own company
these methods are a little different in
how they perform the extraction and
combining of samples but basically they
incorporate heavy isotope labels
directly into the experimental design
so that you can get features related
back to biology
this process really started when gary
and aaron were at a conference one day
and basically gary said you know hey i
was wondering if we could use iron
mobility spectrometry to help separate
and characterize some of these
challenging metabolites
that we're seeing in our e coli samples
and aaron said sounds like a great idea
so gary got his student mike wang to
culture some credentialed e coli
he did the extractions and then sent us
the samples at nc state
where we combined them in the various
ratios as needed
and analyzed them by liquid
chromatography and mobility mass spec
of course using the agilent 6560
platform
if you're unfamiliar with iron mobility
spectrometry ims is a gas phase
separation technique
wherein analytes are separated based on
their size and shape in the gas phase
and so
this is really useful for annotating
chemical isomers in your sample like the
cis and trans fatty acid that you're
seeing on the left
they have the same chemical formula and
the only difference there is the
orientation of their double bond
the cis fatty acid is more compact
compared to the trans fatty acid which
is more extended
and so the cis fatty acid has a much
smaller drift time and encounters less
collisions in the gas phase compared to
the trans fatty acid
we take those roger time values and
convert them to collision cross section
values
using a calibration curve and then we
can search those ccs values against
online databases
to use as an additional way to annotate
our chemical unknowns
in these untargeted experiments
and there's been a lot of effort in the
community from both academic and
industrial partners to standardize the
way we collect
and report these ccs values as the
the publication that most pertains to
the talk today is
the collision cross-section compendium
or ccs compendium
that's published by john mcclane's lab
at vanderbilt university
and was largely led by my old co-worker
jackie pakashi
basically the ccs compendium is an
online repository of chemical
information and includes things like uh
compound name molec mass charge ratio of
course
and collision cross section value which
i use to annotate
my chemical unknowns when i started
analyzing these e coli samples that
mike gave me it became pretty apparent
to me that there's a lot of
redundancy in the way you can annotate
the isotopic pairs
in these experiments as i mentioned on
the previous slides the first way to do
that is to correlate
the mass spectral signals based on their
relative intensity match
i usually this is done with a one-to-one
combination as you see in the top left
also i thought it was useful to analyze
just the carbon 12 and carbon 13 samples
and so in that middle pane you can see
that the presence and absence of each
signal and the other
respective sample confirms that they are
directly related to biology and their
isotope
pairs you can also if you analyze these
samples by high resolution
accurate mass instruments like the top
that we have you can use their mass
defect and the chemical formula at the
bottom
to not only verify that the only
difference there is the carbon 13 but
you can also
calculate the chemical formula based on
the number of carbons associated with
the signal
so very useful information for
annotating our unknowns
if you happen to analyze these samples
by chromatography of course you can look
at their extracted ion chromatogram
traces and those should be identical
just based off of the carbon 13 and the
key here is that the on mobility
provides you a
cool snapshot of these features so if
you look at the bottom right hand panel
we have a two dimensional heat map
where black color indicates no on
abundance and the red
correlates ion intensity and so on the
left side at mass 131 we see the carbon
12 signal
on the right 137 we see carbon 13
and you can see that those both those
signals have the same centroidal drift
time at about 16 milliseconds
and that's because that heavy carbon
isotope doesn't really affect the size
the size of the molecule it just affects
the mass and so we take those raw drift
time values and convert them to
collision cross section using that
calibration curve
and when we search the ccs value of 128
angstroms
against the ccs compendium along with
the chemical formula it's pretty
straightforward to get a match to an
acetyl-putrocene
with an exact ccs match i should say
that um
here we do always use msms to confirm
our chemical annotations
but in this case i was able to match it
just based on ccs
ion mobility is also very useful when it
comes to deconvoluting potentially
crowded regions of your chromatographic
separation
so here in the top left we have a base
peak chromatogram for the
helix separation and esi negative mode
at that retention time window selection
you can see that we have several mass
spectra features
and you can tell that there are several
isotopic pairs based just on relative
intensity such as in the blue and green
color
however using nine mobility is extremely
helpful when you analyze those features
of low abundance
so you can see there for the feature in
red or pink
that we have a low abundant feature it's
kind of hard to
link those two signals based just on the
mass measurement in
abundance but when you look at that
separation in the mobility dimension you
can see that drift time correlation
there horizontally and it's
it's very straightforward to annotate
these uh these kind of
link those signals together and the
converse aspect of that is on the right
side where we have
a lone signal that has no abundance
match in the mass dimension
nor does it have a partner in the
horizontal mobility dimension
and so we don't need to worry about this
feature going forward because it
probably arises from background and it's
not related to biology
the mobility alignment feature of ion
mobility in this isotope log workflow
is also very useful when analyzing your
msms data
this slide is pretty crowded so i'll
walk you through it but basically during
our lc separation we had
the dipeptide valve glue and glutamate
coalute
in our helix separation this isn't
really surprising because these two
molecules
are very similar structurally
and so they co-elude but you can see
that the dipeptide is much larger than
the glutamate ion
so it elutes from the drift tube later
compared to the smaller glutamate ion
and this is useful because the glutamate
precursor is actually a
product ion of activation for valve glue
and so when you just analyze these
samples by lcm sms it's kind of hard to
deconvolute that chimeric spectra but
with the mobility separation
l-glutamine is much smaller so it's
readily resolvable from the
the dipeptide i should say that for
glutamate i was able to annotate this
compound again based
on just uh the chemical formula and ccs
you can see the the match to the
literature there on the left side of
your screen
but also what was unique here is that
there are two other isomers in the ccs
compendium
and methyl aspartate no acetyl serine
and those compounds are much smaller in
their ccs compared to glutamic acid
so it was a pretty straightforward
annotation there
i want to close off my talk with a cool
story about the utility of both ion
mobility and chromatography
so when i was analyzing the e coli
extracts i noticed a bimodal
distribution for the
mass charge ratio 565 and i saw two
peaks
at retention time 3.8 and 4.0 and
there's a good bit
there's decent separation there in the
lc dimension
so i pulled the ion mobility spectra out
of each of those respective peaks
and you can see that the early eluder
has a collision cross section of 207
and the later alluder is a little bit
larger at about 208 209 square angstroms
this is a small difference in ccs but it
is was reproducible and is definitely
there
when i looked at that chemical formula
in those ccs's and the compendium
i got very accurate matches to udp
glucose and udp
galactose the two stereoisomers and so i
was pretty confident
that there were two isomers in this
sample the challenge here is that both
these stereoisomers unsurprisingly have
the same msms spectra which you can see
from metlin there on the right so i
can't use that to differentiate them
thankfully sigma aldrich or i should say
millipore sigma now bailed me out on
this
because they actually have standards for
both udp glucose and udb galactose
and we're matching those two compounds
with the standards was very
straightforward and subsequent analysis
so i thought this was really useful
because i wouldn't have known that there
were two
isomers there without the
chromatographic separation
but i wouldn't have been able to
annotate them without the ion mobility
so really cool example there of this
technology
so in conclusion i think that the
isotope logs workflows and non-mobility
are natural fit
they have a lot of experimental
behaviors that that make them uniquely
suited for each other
and of course you need libraries and
standards to validate these annotations
i don't think that's going to change
anytime soon
for future applications of this work i
think that time scale experiments or
flux analysis or even tracer work could
be very useful
and on mobility helps provide you a
snapshot of those
credentialed metabolism verified
isotopic pairs
i'd like to thank my lab members for all
their help on this talk
our collaborators gary and mike at
washington university
and of course i'd like to thank agilent
technologies for my uh
for for supporting our research there in
the baker lab and in particular here
with the steve burger award
uh those are the other sources of
funding i'd have or i have and i'd be
glad to take any questions
you may have
hmm
hey can you hear me uh antonio
all right so it seems like susie's
having a little bit of technical
difficulties
uh here on her end i don't know
if i can see any of the question and
answer
uh comments uh from my screen
um but i will say
uh one of the things that i get asked
most often about this
work is if the credentialing process can
also apply or excuse me the immobility
verification part can also apply
to iroa
and the miracle platforms there's also
another lipid
isotope log workflow as well the answer
is absolutely yes to all those questions
the method is the same it's just
annotating uh
isotope as by ion mobility so
um the manage q a session is at the very
bottom of my screen
um so i see that
oh okay oh i see okay for the questions
coming through
um uh so
for attending mall one of the uh people
in the audience wants to know what kind
of multi-top top you're using
yeah so the instrument that we use for
these experiments is uh
cyax moly tough 4800 system
and also one other important thing is
this
instrument has a laser with a diameter
of
50 micrometers so that decides the image
resolution of the
analysis so the image resolution of our
data is 50 micrometers
perfect thank you and gentlemen i
apologize
for my little technical problem there so
this next question is for you james
you showed in your talk that ion
mobility can help
provide some ways to link the isotopic
pairs for the credentialing process does
this work for roa
and miracle as well yeah yeah absolutely
they all
function very similarly in terms of how
they generate their isotopologued
metabolites
um there's just various slight nuances
in how they combine those extracts
so ion mobility is extremely useful and
it doesn't matter whether you use
like fames or trapped on mobility or
traveling wave
all of those platforms will do very
similar
analyses for this and really the
challenge is the data analysis right now
which is
is currently manual but that's a good
question
thank you and i want to thank our
audience members for these great
questions
coming in channel you
showed pi pip and pip data
for the fatty acid composition have you
looked at other fast
fatty acid composition for these
molecules
yeah so um
so in this analysis we do see
several fatty acid compositions for for
pi
pip and for pip2
the data that i have shown is with the
fatty acid composition of 38 carbon and
four double bonds which is
one fatty acid is 20 carbon with four
double bonds and the other fatty acid is
18 carbons
uh so this compression is the most uh
most abundant composition
in the mammalian cell so
that's why i showed that one uh but we
do have data for
other compositions as well
and from those data what we observe is
the same
uh same observation where the pip2 and
pip
is duplicated in week 3 and week
week 9 uh npc one celeb
um so yeah it is it is important to look
at different fatty acid if the fatty
acid
chain length is different and if they
are showing different trends
that might that may be meaningful for
this study
but in this case i would say the changes
that we see
is related to the head group so it does
not
depend on the composition of the fatty
acid
yeah thanks thank you
and i do want to remind our audience
members that if you have any questions
you'd like to ask
just do so simply click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
okay our next question is for you james
the massive um scamp yeah besides it
equation
um says that the heavy labeled isotopes
should have a larger ccs
drift time compared to the light
metabolites
why do they have the same drift time
in your results yeah so so by
uh first principles of kinetic theory
and the mission champ equation basically
the
um although the the shape and size of
each of the
the c12 and c13 labeled molecules is the
same
the mass is actually a component of that
equation and so
since the mass of the carbon-13 isotopes
is a bit
more the ccs should be larger and then
the drift time itself should also be
larger as well
uh that is true if you look at the
centroids
of the drift time for the c12 and c13
isotopes
generally speaking the c13 one is a bit
larger
but the difference we're talking about
here is approaching the area of
reproducibility of our instrument
and you need much more uh higher
resolving power to be able to really
distinguish that every single time
so you need something like the the slim
or the mobile ion to sort of get in get
into that realm
thank you and try them all can you
comment
on the amount of material needed for
this awesome innocent tide
analysis yeah
so um so in this study
i did several analysis uh one is from
the
[Music]
mouse cerebellar extract and other
analysis is for the myelin so
also i use two instruments um so in
terms of instruments uh
so i use uh agilent 6545
instrument and also i use ign 6550
so which which has a high higher
sensitivity
so for the 6545 when i do
this analysis in that instrument i
usually starts with
at least 150 micrograms of protein
equivalent so i normalize always with
the protein
protein compression and this is for the
brain tissues
so take 150 micrograms of
protein in colon at least from the
samples and then
do the repeat extraction derivatize and
then
i inject in the 40 65 45 i inject
in between 10 to 20 micrograms
and that gives a very good signal and
so when i did the myelin isolation
so because i did the myelin isolation
from a cerebellum
especially at three weeks i do not get
that much of material
so what i did is i did this analysis
with
50 microgram protein equivalent also i
have done this analysis for cells
using 50 micrograms 14 equivalents using
6550 instrument and so i extract the
lipids out of
50 microgram protein equivalent and
inject 0.5 to 1 micrograms
that gives a very good signal but i do
want to mention
uh when when doing this analysis one
very important thing is this
derivatization reaction
and it uh it heavily depends on the
quality of the reagent i do have
i do have seen sometimes the reagent
does not work if you keep it outside for
a long time
so i would recommend if you do if you
want to do this experiment always keep
this reagent in for c and
uh check the derivatization reaction
using
standards yeah thank you thank you so
much
and james this next question is a
two-part question
do you find any issues with incomplete
incorporation of
c13 during culturing and can you detect
this
in your experimental platform so to be
honest this isn't something
i've i've dived into too deep and i
don't know
if the way you evaluate that is if you
look at the
where the c13 pick is in the mass
spectra and then look
sort of well it'd be to the left on the
mass scale
if there's if there's not complete
incorporation of the c13 tag
if that's so maybe a little bit
um but not much i see that in in i don't
know if there's any way to get feedback
on if this is correct but i think the
question's coming from
fernando tobias at ohio state uh if so
and i can send you an email after this
following up and clarifying uh what you
mean and then i can go back and look at
the data but i'm i think you would
evaluate that
on the left side of the c13 peak it
seems to be pretty good for me
again i didn't do the uh the extraction
so i can't say
anything about that part but i can
definitely send you a private email
after this is over and you can sort of
let me know what you're thinking thanks
james and here's another one for you
actually
would the traveling wave ion mobility
and trapped ion ability mobility
instruments
provide similar results with a
credentialed metabolite
yeah they should do exactly the same
thing in terms of their
alignment of those isotopologs
with the newer traveling wave and the
trapped ion mobility you'll get more
resolving power so you might start to
see the c13 peak
grow a little bit quote unquote and ccs
relative to the c12
but as far as feature finding and things
like that go it should still be very
straightforward
thank you and we have time for a couple
more questions shawna
have you considered doing ims to support
the differentiation of isomers of pip2
oh that's a great question um
yeah we have we have tried
also i think this is something that i i
would like to talk to james too because
he has been working on ims
um yeah so it it gives a good separation
for pip two actually
uh but monophosphate is the ones that we
are having troubles to separate because
it has only one phosphate and only the
position
is the is different uh but yeah
i would like to work more on ims
in order to uh try to separate this in
ims
thanks for the question uh financial
bias
yeah yeah to that point yeah
oh i mean a lot of feedback there um
yeah at uh
nc state we have a collaboration with
dave muddyman and i saw that you had
uh looked at the msi platform to do your
data analysis
um and so we used uh dave muddyman's
maldessi ir maldesk source
on the agilent 6560 in a very crude
setup
and it it does work you have to sync the
laser pulse with the
uh uh trap release time in the drift
tube
and it and it can work and i think
there's definitely some
room there for uh to get that going i
think brooker is also trying to get the
timstoff to have their uh
maldi source on the front and i think
that's that's a good thing to look into
too so you might so you might be
interested in that work
yeah yeah definitely yeah thanks i will
look into that more
thank you both and we have time for one
more question
this last question from an audience
member doesn't have it's not directed to
either one of you
so one of you can choose to answer what
model
of multi tos pof was used
oh that's for that's for my experiment i
use a
abc x multi dot for the 800 system
thank you for that and thank you both
for your time today and for your
important research
would either let you like to have any
closing remarks before we
you close today first if you want
yeah go ahead oh okay um no i i
i think it's it's been a very good talk
and i think that
the key at least from what i saw both of
our talks is it's very hard to pinpoint
molecular structures due to a lot of
isomers
and i think that you know msms9 mobility
in conjunction with chromatography is a
very good way to go
yeah um from this uh especially from
this asms i learned
a lot of new advances in the field
uh that can be used for molecule
identification
and it has been very helpful having this
conference
in online state in online format so
i think uh mass spectrometric recent
advances
are very useful in terms of biological
analysis to answer biological questions
and also i would like to thank agilent
for especially arranging this
virtual event and giving us the
opportunity to present our
can get feedback it has been very
helpful those questions and everything
thank you very much absolutely
and i want to thank you both again for
this presentation and for your time
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand through
june of 2021 until next time
be safe take care bye